your grandmother ken she did come to to
britain to see she saw you on stage he
did eventually i mean she she uh
she was really sort of built into the
fabric of belfast but we got her out to
england once and uh
she laughed the idea of me being an
actor many people did but um she was
baffled by it so we took her to see me
in a play
um and she was with my parents i was
playing uh saint francis of assisi a
nice protestant lad and
and we put her in the front row and we
gave her the little opera glasses you
know because her eyesight wasn't so good
only problem was that in playing francis
who was an ordinary man at the beginning
of the play i find god and in the way of
saints when i find god i have to be born
again and when i'm born again i have to
be born naked
so i'm going to take my kit off in front
of my granny she's in the front row
she's got the opera glass i think i'll
bugger this i thought bunga just go for
it just go for it so get to the end of
the first half walk down i think i can
do this and i go yeah i get ready for
the big end of first act finish father
father tis i i am born again
don't just go for it i felt like danny
dyer on the wall
drop him
it was block and tackle going crown
jewels in the wind but i've got them
total silence they're listening
you know you could you could hear a pin
drop absolute rapture at the site of
great acting and then i hear from the
back of the auditorium a voice say i've
seen more meat on a dirty fork
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not very helpful and then my granny she
stands up she turns around she holds up
the opera glasses and says use your
binoculars it looks like a bloody hot
dog
so
she was she she was always protecting me
[Applause]
[Music]